did youever think you
make Victory I know this
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David giv values contagious this
world are entrepreneurs we get no value
to haters run homie look what I become
I'm the I'm the
one rap could pass for an Armenian
anyways okay episode 335 today I don't
know this could be considered a Guinness
book of a world record right for to
getting in this Vault right now okay
there's four Assyrians wow whether you
like it or not Rob for the next two
hours you're also see what I teach you
he looks like a sh he looks like
a bald in a beard he could be a Deon he
looks like he can pass so let me let me
properly introduce you know we've been
wanting to do this for a minute and I
thought it was just great to do
everybody together so let let me go
through it you already know Vinnie
Vinnie's the how do I properly introduce
Vinnie Vinnie is one of the best looking
guys I know Vinnie's face is like a
Hollywood Robert Downey junor Tom Cruz
too much all we we'll leave you alone
but let me let me go through our our two
other friends here the other one is uh
Mr Checkmate George enko okay who's a
great chess player uh uh here's a guy
that I don't know why you like traveling
you don't mind traveling you like going
to placees where there's a lot of water
but you'll go but for whatever reason
you don't like boys on Islands I don't
know what it is with you you don't like
island boys who wrote that for you man
nobody we actually don't do any of it
right we don't write uh George is one of
the coolest cats out there you and I had
a chance to do something together you
came here we do a podcast I after you
were done I I liked you 10 times more
because of what I learned about your
relationship with your pops your family
character values all of that stuff I
appreciate it but funny guy cool cat we
were at dude what time do we rap it was
a school night you get 12:30 we're still
at the house having a conversation
together well my defense it took a very
long time to walk through your
establishment your house took like and
you know what's so funny we walked into
rooms and he's like I've never even been
here and I've been here for almost two
years I was like wait what but here's
the kicker the reason why we're here
here we can always hang God the reason
why we chose to do everybody together is
because of Bishop Mari okay and we
started talking about you and you know
uh Rob for a while you and I we've been
wanting to do something and we wanted to
make sure it was the right time we were
so glad cuz you're all the way on the
other side correct you you got you got
thousands of miles to travel to come
here from Australia did and to properly
introduce him you know one thing is
foref fact even though he's visiting the
states I think it's fair to say you will
not be having dinner with Mr fouchi is
is that a fair assessment to say there
won't be a absolutely correct okay so
known for his wisdom passion you by the
way you've seen him going viral with the
values and principles he stands for it's
just absolutely wonderful watching the
fact that you have the kind of a
backbone that you're not willing to just
get up there and say what you're
supposed to be saying you're the example
of a person who believes what the book
He follows says and you're not tolerant
about wanting to break those values and
principles like we are seeing right now
some of the places taking place which we
will definitely be talking about having
said that it's an honor to have you here
the honor is all ours thank you so much
dear Patrick and uh the beautiful
Assyrian Brothers here that we are I'm
with I don't know it's like a dream come
true I've always um I've never thought
that it was a day going to come to to be
in this beautiful place with all of you
so I I thank the Lord Jesus for all of
you and uh for this beautiful and
Priceless moment to be with you thank
you trust me I feel uh honored to have
you here but I appreciate those kind
words so we got a lot of things to cover
right we got a lot of things to cover
because everybody is here from a bit of
a different background but there is a
common threat that we have with our
background being a Syrian and our faith
you have it on your wrist right there if
someone's looking at you you're pretty
proud of where your faith is uh I think
even when you guys run the podcast with
Logan Paul we'll talk about that where
you would share your faith and it was a
bit of a you know push back on going
back and forth and some of the Christian
Comm like wait a minute that was kind of
awkward what happened between you and
him and then Vinnie uh uh being who he's
at you know military background you know
and then from their comedy you've been a
bunch of different things you've done a
bunch of movies but now Church Sundays
and then here yourself as well so
Assyrians I'll start off with you if you
don't mind Bishop to the average person
that maybe doesn't know Assyrians when I
would go to clubs in Vegas in the in the
Army I know that's kind of like a weird
transition from aition to clubs I'm in
naville I'm going to clubs and people
would tell me say hey what's your name
Patrick so where you from Assyrian oh
you're Sicilian no I'm Assyrian what so
you're Syrian no a Syrian what are
syrians right what do you say to people
the average person that says what is an
Assyrian I think um um when we go back
to history and we call um the word
Mesopotamia out I think that sayar all
Mesopotamia and Assyrian bah between the
two rivers of tigers and Euphrates in a
biblical sense um after the great flood
of our father no um they went to a place
called chinar which is which is
Mesopotamia B and that's where they were
tried to build that Tower of Babel so um
on the other hand um uh you look at um
at the descendants of of Noah Shem we
are the descendants of Shem and one of
his sons is actually ashur and that's
where ashaya comes from so there is a
lot of history and um Iraq is the center
and the Heart of all of this um so when
you mention that a lot of people are
more familiar with the history of that
instead of just saying I'm an Assyrian
because as you mentioned dear Patrick
they do mix it with Syrian or Sicilian
so yeah so but when you mention Iraq
Mesopotamia and the history behind it um
they become sort of more oh yes I I get
it now and and you you are you were born
in Iraq so when you st in Iraq so so
George for yourself you know you're
you're mainstream you're all over the
place right you've gone viral from Vine
days you've got billions of views people
recognize your face on what you've done
fun likable guy smart at the same time
but you're also will defend your faith
when people ask you what is an Assyrian
how do you answer what do you say I
actually uh it's it's kind of one of my
my favorite flexes you know that's cool
you have a Lamborghini but I spoke the
language that Jesus Christ spoke and I
just don't think anything is cooler than
that and so I think that's my like my my
favorite go-to I'm like have you seen
Passion of the Christ I did not need to
read the subad and uh I just find that
so cool I like it it's I feel like in
the day that we live the scarcity is
quality right I mean we just said this
is a world record for syrians being in
one room uh when I was younger I always
wanted to be uh something else because I
wasn't ashamed but I wasn't common with
people like nobody understood where I
came from no one understood my
background so as I grew up I realized
what a blessing it was to to see like
when people bring up the Bible and they
try to say and they're saying it in
their language and I'm like oh cool this
is so cool this is my language and I
don't know I I don't like to take a lot
of pride in things but that I find that
to be a really fascinating thing that we
have the same di di blood blood yeah and
you're right about passion the Christ uh
by the way did you watch in the movie
theater did you did you watch the movie
in the theater or in in DVD do you
remember the first time you watch in the
theater I watch it in the military in
the theater I remember was there
protesting going cuz the one I went to
there was protesting no no this was this
this was in of all places in Montana
people were cry nobody was it was one of
those moments where people the lights
are on people are crying people are
emotional and I the first thing I said
Pat I was like whoever Mel Gibson hired
for his Di
coach whatever she was it was a female
nailed it cuz the majority of the movie
I was listening instead of reading and
by the way it amazing while you're
saying this George three and a half
million Assyrians worldwide 8 billion
you know total world population I just
did the numbers here to know that we are
qualified endangered species so folks
you may want to take a picture because
this may be and put it up on the board
cuz this rarely happens it's the the the
odds of you running into an Assyrian is
point
.4% of running into an Assyrian so this
is a miracle Vinnie when somebody ask
you what's in Assyrian what do you say
oh man um cuz I like what he said you
know the fact that the you know easy
following up with me budy yeah well pass
of the Christ and all that but uh but I
mean he made a really good point uh when
I tell him it's always it's I you have
to be knowledge in sud and ass Syrian to
give them the report cuz how many times
have you said this which I'm pretty sure
YouTu Bishop where you go no I'm a
Syrian and they say oh so Syria you're
Muslim I'm like no no I am a Syrian and
then the history report of the tiger and
Euphrates River the you know the cradle
of civilization but then people and and
then I'm going to defense mode CU
they're like well dude you guys don't
even have a country you're you're not
really and then my my proof is I go then
how do I speak aric how show me how I
speak the language of Jesus Christ so
then I have to go into the lineage and
how Assyrians are scattered we're
basically Nomads and we're everywhere
but the contributions that we did so it
goes from history report to George na
bro I I as a young person you didn't get
it okay we're in church we're in um
we're running around yeah yeah but to
sit down and really understand and soak
in they would call my father God Rest
the soul they'd call him nve cuz he
cared about Assyrians and was trying to
put the word out it's just you know
we're at the point where we're
endangered but I guess we talked about
this earlier Pat it's our job to keep
talking about it keep going it out
because if we don't then who who else is
going to do it and we need to have a lot
of babies is what we need to do way let
me let me just kind of give you
what did Assyrians invent if you're
writing it's because of Assyrians
writing literature started off by
Assyrians first Library Assyrians paved
roads 360° Circle math first Warriors
the list of it goes on and on and on and
and I'm Armenian and Assyrian the other
day an Armenian brother was fighting an
Assyrian guy Assyrian benil he was
supposed to be here him and I were
talking he couldn't make it and they're
like who are you rooting for I'm like
dude I'm half Armenian half Assyrian
this is why my parents got a divorce
twice to each other but uh but answer
the question who you rooting for I was I
was probably rooting for benil because I
have a relationship with him because him
and I were talking so I I I I was
rooting for him I don't know the other
Armenian guy seems like a real solid
fighter but uh benil and I were talking
but you there's a lot of things with our
uh uh Heritage but again the question
comes how come we don't have a land so
there's a few things I want to talk
about today one thing I want to talk
about what is up with the Assyrian
Community that's one uh there's an
element of competition you know the
older older folks ass syrians don't
believe the younger people know what
they're talking about and at one point I
wanted to kind of contribute and help
out and I saw what it was being shun
away you know you kind of like you don't
know what you're talking about no
problem then I'll go do my thing with
business then I want to talk about a
little bit of faith on where we are
today and then some current event issues
that I have written here as well that
we'll get into as well but maybe the
first thing to talk about is we can
start off with the Assyrian side you you
know the Israeli they didn't have a land
for a long time they eventually got it
okay and now you know they are where
they are a lot of people went back
they're they're workers they're you know
entrepreneurs they business people they
get criticized a lot the world you know
Germany tried to eliminate them and
literally the face of the planet and
they didn't succeed So eventually
they're able to go back and done what
they've done but as syrians we have a
land it's in Iraq you know you saw last
year or two years ago they were trying
to get rid of all the art and you know
statues and stuff that we have to get
rid of any of the history that we have
why do you think the Assyrian community
and maybe you may disagree with me why
do you think the Assyrian Community
isn't United why do you think they're
divided well that's a very good question
and I
um I don't know if I'm going to give it
justice in a um in a short time I just
want to say one thing I believe the
Assyrians of our time and age there are
two things that we struggle with
and they I believe they are the main
reason why we are not being united one
there is too much self- pride and
secondly there is a tribal influence
within the Assyrian Community for
example
um the first thing they will ask where
you from what is your trouble background
and if you are for example jila Ora Ora
orara all these tribes are becoming
really a stumbling stone for us to be
really United and even within the church
parameter we see that is happening as
well I believe we need to just come back
and say we are Assyrians period and
that's where the unity of the nation is
yes I I am proud of my Heritage of my
background of the village I was I come
from my parents my my grandparents but
at the same time uh I need to keep that
identity for me personally but on a
larger scale I am an Assyrian and that
should be the end of the story so uh
tribal influence should not come into
the play where it becomes a stumbling
Stone of our unity and then they say
where are you from are you Assyrian from
Iraq from Lebanon from Syria from Iran
well it doesn't matter where I come from
but I am an Assyrian so what's the
difference if I was born in Iran or Iraq
or anywhere else we are Assyrians and
that's what should read unite us and be
above all um so we need to really focus
on this and try and rectify it and solve
it otherwise we will always be um going
in a circle George you're a very
well-known Assyrian young Community
Assyrians know you people know you
period but the young Community Assyrians
they all know you right within your
experience in the Assyrian side have you
tried what has been your experience when
it comes down to trying to unify get
together you know amplify the the cause
the message the background what's been
your experience um great question uh
tough question because sometimes you
want to answer with your heart but uh it
doesn't really nail on the ears of
people that should be hearing it but my
point of view is this first before
anything before even my parents it comes
Christ that goes above all so um with
respect to this gentleman next to me
regardless of his stature his cloth or
his badge if he goes against
against my God that I I humbly try to
convince him otherwise I think being
humble has kind of been eliminated and
when he was talking about Pride I very
much agree with him there's a lot of
Pride um I was reading I was reading
Mark yesterday in the St Mark in in the
gospel and I found something really
fascinating Judas was the
disciple that basically crucified Jesus
he sold him out for the world
but if you look at the scripture Christ
treated Judas the same way he treated
the other disciples even though he knew
this gentleman was the one who was wrong
he was the he was the one that wasn't
going to reap what he sowed if you if
you understand what I'm
saying I think what happened was there's
a division there's the people that move
with pride and they're like no no no
Assyrians Traditions first and then the
gospel and then the people that are
fighting for the gospel they they're
fighting with no love they don't want
any understanding they want no
compassion and so if I sit there with
hotty eyes looking at an Asser man being
like look at all what you've done is
wrong I got to remember that what I
measure that man God will measure me and
when God came down he didn't come with
his finger in his face being like you
guys are wrong you're out of here he led
with an example and I want it to part
from my church because there was a lot
of things that I saw my church do that I
I felt like wasn't acceptable and then I
went to this church and this church had
problems and then I went to this church
and then this church had problems and
then I realized a house that is divided
cannot stand but there is no house that
is not divided and so what happens is
Satan regardless of what this gentleman
does say this gentleman right here
before me God does use him and he builds
a beautiful church but then when he
passes away satana and that's Satan in
Assyrian will come through another man
and he will make himself a board member
or he'll hold the money and he'll make
decisions that are corrupted that
doesn't blame him and I don't blame my
for it or but I do want to have people
to stop being scared of holding people
accountable if this gentleman was
running my church I am going to listen
to him because God gave him permission
to run my church and I will honor him
but if I see him step out of line of the
true Commander I'm not going to
disrespect him and embarrass him in
front of his people but I'm going to
pull him aside and be like hey
likea this is saying this and that but
we're doing this and this why is that
and I think if you come from Love and
come with an understanding of a heart
then I think we could have a
conversation but I think our our
bloodline are Warrior so they want to
fight first plant their flag and then
show love but that's the exact opposite
of what God did he came with love and
then that planted his
flag what's what's prompting you to go
there first because did you did you have
an experience where uh uh that happened
with an Assyrian church that's put that
bitter taste in your mouth yeah but it's
it's not and I don't mean a specific
example I'm just wondered it sounds like
you've gone through it before yeah it is
but it isn't just my Assyrian church
it's every church right I think when a
man becomes a man he thinks everything
he knows is correct right but then he
grows to be wiser like you're probably
wiser than you were five years ago so
you would probably doubt half of the
opinions you've made so when I came I I
was there and I would love to get into
this and understand your point of view
because you are more educated in in this
scripture than I am but for example um I
didn't understand fasting to Saints
didn't understand it it's against our
gospel um and there's only one mediator
between God and me and it's Christ and
so I was talking to a gentleman and he
told me um I think he got overwhelmed I
will give I'll give him this I think he
was overwhelmed because I knew the
scripture very well and he says who are
you to speak to God alone and and that
kind of threw me in a loop but then I
realized that what happened was he
became prideful and I became prideful
and Satan had a field day with both of
our hearts it did no one came to the
table with the understanding of what
does God want first and I think that's
what we need to do there's a Bible verse
that I I love that I love to explain to
people because I have conversations with
people that view God differently right
in the book of um Jonah when he was on
the boat and everyone was freaking out
because there was apparently a God who
was very upset and they're like who's
God is mad at them they all prayed to
their God but eventually they knew whose
God was real and I think that's all it
needs I think a lot of people want to
put it in their hands when it really
should be given to God's hands and so if
your church and your eyes is wrong or
your home is wrong for example of Bobby
my father if he's wrong I have no
jurisdiction or right to go above my
father and say Dad you're wrong but I
could lead with an example and then I
could ask my God to soften his heart and
open his eyes and his ears but I would
never disrespect my father one in front
of people ever what is the outcome what
what is the outcome Bishop Mari what is
the outcome of what Assyrians should
strive for meaning um for example right
now what's going on in America you know
America's losing its identity right what
it was who it was too soft it forgotten
that we became what we became because
America was favored by God and maybe
we've lost that favor arrogance whatever
may be what should be the Assyrian
community's Vision to unify behind is it
to get the land back to Assyrians what
what should be the vision of the
Assyrian
Community I um I agree with my beloved
George what he said um God is the is the
unifier definitely before we go and
speak about getting the land back we
need to focus on on getting our children
back because they are our home they are
our country what's the point of getting
a piece of land but I don't have the
people that will live there and make a
good use of that land I
need as a as an Assyrian Nation we go
back in history however we came to know
Christ from a very very long time and
the Church of the East is one of the
earliest churches really after Jerusalem
that embraced the Lord Jesus and
Christianity came um St ad and St Mari
were uh St ad was the one who was
actually sent by the Lord Jesus to King
abgar okama uh which is now known turkey
current turkey but that was part of all
the Assyrian Nation um so when they
Embrace Christianity and being the
nation that speak spoke and still speak
the Aramaic language the Lord's the
Lord's language till now all our church
services are an Aramaic um so when they
Embrace that Christianity um it's been
embedded in us for over 2,000 years we
cannot deny this fact that we need to go
back and acknowledge Christ as the head
of this nation you see if we do not have
the fear of God we will not have the
fear
of one another and what I mean by fear
is that love we are missing true genuine
love true genuine love is missing in us
when I say to Patrick to George to to
Vinnie that you are my brothers in
Christ and I love you I need to mean it
I need to be genuine in it when I say it
in front of you or behind your back it
should be the same way character is
missing in here so
I need to build a
generation that is God-fearing and this
God is Jesus Christ of
Nazareth this is what our nation is
missing both in the church and on a
secular sort of uh part of it
[Music]
um I don't know but
unfortunately and I don't know I may
sound a little bit maybe blunt here so I
do ask for forgiveness if I I you know
sound any offensive here but from a a
church point of view being a a bishop in
the church
um the focus is not on the Lord Jesus
100% I want say it the focus is not
there totally but there is a huge
percentage the focus is not on Christ
Christ when you look at
him the first thing that we need to
learn is
humility because humility is the key to
success again as a nation um when I see
someone who is an Assyrian and is
successful in whichever field they are I
should be very proud to have an Assyrian
who is successful in that field instead
of um maybe challenging that person or
trying to go against that person I
rather need to be supportive and
encouraging others to support that
person because a success of one is
should be the success of
everyone this is what's missing in us as
well we are not supportive of one
another we are not encouraging others to
come on board everybody is seeking their
own throne their own Empire their own
prestigious life their own Fame their
own rank their own position their own
title their own stars but hang on a
second if we are speaking at a
collective level let's assume for a
moment we are in this boat and the boat
is sinking does it really matter if I'm
the captain or just a normal simple uh
sailor when the boat sinks guess what
everybody's going down the ocean does
not differentiate between the captain
who is in charge and who is not we need
to come together and Salvage the
situation we need to try everything
possible to to make sure this board
doesn't sing because when it goes down
everybody goes down this is the problem
I believe our focus is not in a
collective way it is in an
individualistic way and individualism is
weak individualism is weak now the
language of love is we but the language
of selfishness is
I when the disciples asked the Lord
Jesus teach us on how to pray the Lord's
Prayer in Matthew 69 and Luke
11:3 the Lord immediately said every
time you pray you say our father he
taught the by the way he taught the the
prayer in the Aramaic language and the
Aramaic language is the informal
language at the time of the Lord Jesus
the formal language was Hebrew and the
informal was Aramaic meaning at home in
the streets and the shops they used
Aramaic but but the formal language in
the synagogues and any government
official bodies was the Hebrew language
so whenever the Lord entered the
synagogue he needed to speak in Hebrew
but with the disciples on the way to
Galilee and other parts of Israel he
spoke Aramaic to them so when he T the
prayer he said every time you say you
say
or depending on the dialect whether it's
eastern or
western um but he started with the Our
Father the pluralistic language see I
could be standing in my room alone and I
will still speak the plural language and
I'll say our father I'll never say my
father because my father is kind of
selfish very powerful so for example um
the president of the United States of
America whenever he stands and give a
talk he will never use the singular
format he will he will always say we
well how many of you it's only me but
the position you hold is the superpower
of the world so when you speak in a
language that is powerful it is
reflective of the position you
hold there is power in unity and there
is weakness in division God is the god
of unity Jesus Christ of Nazareth is the
king of peace I wrote a few things down
here you said a lot and George I I I
kind of got where you're going as well
what is the difference between Assyrians
and Jews Assyrians have been around a
thousand years before Jews right uh when
I talk to myw friends you know I tell
this story about the first time in my
life I saw $6 million cash a guy who was
running a very successful business in in
uh Valley California I said why is it
that Jews are so successful in business
he says because when one makes money
five make money yes he says all the
other ethnicities when one makes money
only one makes money he says this is why
we're always united we are so strong
watch this I'm working with these group
of Mormons in this one company and this
movie comes out called Napoleon Dynamite
and they come back from the theater on
Monday and they're telling me you know
Napoleon Dynamite's going to win an
Oscar I'm like you got to be kidding me
they said John heer may be one of the
greatest actors of all time said I'm a
movie guy I go to the movies on you know
that next weekend I watched I said this
is one of the worst movies I've seen in
my life why did you say this the
greatest movie all the time they didn't
want to tell me anything that guy's a
Mormon that guy right there is a Mormon
so I'm like okay don't play the clip cuz
YouTube will take it and do it so to us
you're like okay you guys are very
United Mormons United Jews United
Muslims United God forbid you say
something about Muhammad they are very
United why is it when you see these
communities being united why are Syrian
so much you know an element of division
and especially with a civilization
that's been around for thousand years so
that's been around a thousand years more
than you know Jews give or take the
numbers shouldn't we have a land
shouldn't we be together what is the
difference between Assyrians and
Jews that goes to all of you guys but
yeah absolutely look um I believe if I
if we were to put two people in the same
situation you'll always see there is an
outcome different to the other I
remember there was once uh they showed
on television back in Australia in
Sydney uh two twin brothers two twin
brothers um one was was an one one ended
up being an alcoholic the other one was
a very successful businessman MH they
interviewed both and look at what they
said twin brothers the alcoholic one
they said why did he end up being an
alcoholic he said my dad was an
alcoholic and that's all I knew growing
up I became like dad the other one they
said well why did you become a su
successful businessman he said when I
saw my dad the way he was I decided for
myself whatever happens I will never end
up like that I'll make sure I will be
totally different to prove to my dad
that I can make it if you couldn't the
problem with us is we need to use our
heads not our emotions sometimes we
become too emotional with things where
we need to be more um logical with
things now what does it as the Lord
Jesus said what does it benefit a man if
he gains the whole world and then loses
himself at the end I cannot be selfish
why because what have I gained by being
selfish I just want to be successful for
me Rich for myself um I need to make it
to the shores of Peace On My Own what am
I going to benefit if I enter Paradise
alone Paradise without people with me I
don't think it's a really happy place to
be I need to take people with me so I
need to think and use my head what am I
gaining if the whole world is just
looking at me And yet my brothers and
sisters in Christ and the Assyrian
Nation are left behind I look at it now
for example as a Christian in the
church people come and the hundreds and
the thousands and they say Bishop we
love you this and that and they bow and
respect and and all all the all the rest
of it but then I'm sitting on that High
Throne okay what am I gaining by sitting
on that High Throne yet I have my own
people my own flesh and blood suffering
uh being persecuted all over the world
what am I doing about
this what what is this uniform going to
do and the throne that I sit on going to
do for me if my son my daughter my
brother my sister my father my mother
are left in the
street I'm I'm a loser even if I'm the
pope I'm a
loser
Christ is the
ultimate Christ is the
ultimate you
know when we talk as church
leaders on Earth we need to be Street
Beggars we need to be Street Beggars not
Kings kingship will come in the next
life by the grace of God but on Earth I
need to be a street beggar I need to
walk in the footprints of the Messiah
when they asked the Lord
Jesus do we pay taxes to Caesar or
not do we pay taxes to Caesar or
not the Lord Jesus said give me that
dinari show me that dinari and he asked
him he said whose image and writing is
imprinted on this coin they said Caesar
well he said then render what is
Caesar's to Caesar and what is God's to
God he said how come you people realize
this is Caesar's image and you've known
this is Caesar's image therefore this
coin belongs to Caesar since it's his
image imprinted on it and yet you have
failed to realize whose image is
imprinted on you isn't it God's Genesis
1:26 let us go down and make man in our
image according to our likeness I didn't
come seeking your pocket I came seeking
your hearts
I came seeking that image which was
imprinted on you from the very beginning
which is the image of God love is the
Supreme
ethic this is what we're missing you see
in the church in order for me to
remember my Afflicted brother and sister
my son in Christ my daughter in Christ
in order for me as a church leader to
remember them and not only remember them
to get up from that High Throne and high
place and and be humble and go in that
street and sit at the gutter and share
the meal with that Afflicted person the
only way I can do this when I see myself
as a father not as a
leader but but okay so and I and I agree
but the question becomes does God favor
Jews more than Assyrians did did
Assyrians lose favor of God even though
they've done all the stuff that they've
done was God kind of sitting there
saying go ahead George do you you
understand the question I'm asking yeah
I want to piggy back off of what he said
he brought up Matthew and it was a
beautiful verse when he says what is
Caesar's and what is Gods but if you
continue that Bible verse he says so
that we don't offend
them go to the pond and then there'll be
a fish with a coin in its mouth and I
found that beautiful he is the god of
heaven and in Earth but his first step
was to not offend because once you
offend somebody they stop listening to
you and once they stop listening to you
they only listen to Satan
because then they're not listening to
the gospel
anymore so when you said why is
Assyrians not favored anymore and also
you said we're made in the image of God
and how God created is by first speaking
out into things before Jesus was Jesus
he was the word and then he became the
flesh that's powerful that means that
there's power in your tongue so we
shouldn't be having four mics and for
Assyrians and saying why are Assyrians
so troubled why are they so bad why are
they so broken every ethnicity is
there's just less of us so if we're
going to lead with example we got to
give more not praise because that's it
could lead in the wrong direction but
say our church did fail us say our
people did fail us well God has blessed
us with four microphones that's reaching
millions of people so instead of looking
at what our ancestors did that broke I
don't think that's what we're doing what
what I'm doing here is I'm asking a
question to say if if if you're running
a if anything you run with business or
company
or a sports team or military and you say
this company's been around for this many
years longer we have this many more
patents we have this many more successes
we have this many more things why why is
the company bankrupt today I think you
think I was coming at you in in a in a
way where I think you were coming down
on people I wasn't at all what I was
saying is that I don't think God left
favor at but I think what happens in
business is there's up times and there's
down times and I think right now is a
good moment for us to be up because we
have very powerful positions I do agree
that our church may have gone the wrong
direction I do agree that our people are
lost and I do agree we don't have a land
yeah so so then what is that though so
so if let's just say you know Assyrians
are going to be watching this whether
different age categories different
backgrounds different Financial
situations there in from different parts
of the world they're going to be
listening to this and they're probably
in the same place when they're going and
explaining somebody that I'm an Assyrian
like what is an Syrian they're probably
going through the same thing there's
three and a half million of us right a
lot of Assyrians I know they're workers
they're value based people they get
things done they're good Fathers they
value family they're these are all
things that you ought of value to have
in your community if you live in a
community with Assyrians there you
probably like these Assyrians you
probably like spending time with them
you probably like your kids being with
their kids and going over to their house
I'm asking a bigger question question I
I I don't you know to me small things
are great I I want to s for big things
and big things would be you know when
I'm having a Crown Prince here and we're
having a conversation about how to
create democracy in Iran how do we do
that I want take my kids back to Iran
and show them hey here's where I was
raised I'm a Syrian and I'm Armenian and
I was born in Iran and I Was Made in
America so to me those four places
matter to me a lot yes why why don't
what do Assyrians need to do is it
really truly faithful first and let's
just say if it is then what is it what
needs to be next and what is that goal
look as I going back to that like real
example between the two twin brothers
why did this one decided to be like that
and the other one totally opposite to
that I I believe uh experiences in life
should be a very very U valuable lesson
for all of us so we need to learn from
the successes and the failures and we
all go through successes and failures
and and taken as as a nation All Nations
do go through that but the thing I pray
for our Assyrian nation is to learn from
the experiences of life in the past and
try to come up with a better way of
making the future more brighter for the
whole nation um until now I don't think
we have reached that level uh to say
that we have learned from our failures
in the past to try make a a better
future and a and more successful future
we still have divisions uh W within
within our na Nation we still have
divisions with our within our own church
as well so how can then we have a land
when we are really divided and and so
many factions it is impossible
impossible so we need to come back and
re and say until when are we going to
remain in division until when as you
mentioned dear Patrick earlier our
beloved Jews okay when it comes to
nationalism they all are united they all
come into it and they need to support
their Nation their country their their
identity we need to do the same thing
but we are still fighting over trivial
things that are really not worth you
know spending that time on we need to
move away from that haunting past where
it's bringing more and more Division and
we need to find a way to come into unity
and say
this is the way we need to do it but
what are we solving for though what do
we I guess what I'm trying for example
uh on the Armenian side there're super
United yes not 100% they still have the
Armenian from Lebanon baraha yavan all
this but they're Armenians are united
right corre correct um you know uh uh
when it comes on to the Assyrian side
what dream are we selling what are we
pursuing because if there's not a dream
then say somebody that's in political
power they don't know how to help they
don't know how to contribute say
somebody a military leader and they're
Syrian they don't know how to up they
don't know how to cont say somebody's in
a Hollywood or media space they don't
know how to what am I what is the vision
what are we doing what Vision are we
selling for like even if we were to call
a meeting together and we brought the
top 100 most influential Assyrians
together in the same room great what are
we solving for what should be the vision
is it just let's all come together and
you know be aligned with God and you
know work together as a team or should
there be something to say no here's the
vision why don't we aim at dot dot dot
dot dot as the Assyrian Vision that's
kind of where I'm going with this go
ahead uh in the Scripture it say and I
only bring up scripture because I know
the people that are listening are uh or
dedicated listeners are going to be
Assyrians right and I want to speak uh
the language that we all understand and
it's the gospel um seek first the
kingdom and the rest shall follow amen
okay so if we all unite who Christ is
then we could use these as blocks and
remember Jews are very powerful but they
didn't have Jerusalem they lost that and
then that got it back so what I believe
is that if we all as good children are
united then the father will reward the
children amen but I think that if the
children are divided you have children
and you what I love my favorite part
about spending time with you is I even
asked Andrew t i I brought up who are
the three top fathers that you think and
I brought you up because I truly when I
looked at the way you ran your house I
asked God if I could do half of this
man's work then I'll be good my children
will be set but in the very very very
beginning of any household and anything
is who's in
charge who is in charge I agree Y and I
think what's happening is so many people
that shouldn't be in charge who is who
it to who in
charge no no but that's what it
understand you're saying I agree God is
in charge totally get it but now who is
that spokesperson for the Assyrian
Community to bring him together an I
don't know the thing is again the tribal
influence we've got a problem
you see um that any human being cannot
be free from Earthly um things and until
they come into this encounter with the
True Divine God we need to come back to
Jesus Christ of Nazareth as a nation I
believe this now some people may
disagree with me some people within the
Assyrian Nation may not even believe in
the Lord Jesus as being God but whether
you accept it or not this is the truth
my dear friend my dear brother my dear
sister we need God in our life in order
to unite first as people then to seek a
place for these people can I challenge
can I challenge that mindset okay I have
a lot of uh uh Jewish friends
who they're they're they'll say they're
Jewish right yes I don't know if you
like they're not yes I'm kind of like
Jewish and they'll do this thing right
but will they go back and serve their
country yes will they go back and do
this yes there's a lot of people that
serve this country and love America and
they're not Christians there's a lot of
people that you know R love the red
white and blue and they're you know
maybe a different denomination or a
different faith and I get that but there
is not 100% of the community is going to
be all behind Team Jesus that's not
going to be 100% there's going to be
some that have pride behind their
Country Pride behind their Land Pride
behind their
blood let him you know then you know
what get out of here you're not going to
be part of the group because you can
still contribute to the to the thing so
maybe the vision's got to be M
multifaceted maybe it's got to be hey of
course at the end of the day if this is
going to happen it's going to happen
because God's hand over to people and
he's going to want to make sure this
becomes a reality but by the way you
know Assyrians uh seized they they were
in power they they ruled for 19
centuries right 600 BC is the last time
we had land that is 2600 years ago we've
been on a slump for a long time our
quarterly earnings have been pretty
terrible for a long time right so all
I'm saying is can we like bring back a
little bit let's let's have one company
go public let's do some things here that
we can start winning again I don't know
if it's just and by the way I think
faith is going to be a conversation I'm
going to go to next yes I what is that
what's winning win here with like
materialistic things or having a great
company or great churches or great
running cuz I know a million churches
that have millions of people and have
millions of dollars but I guarantee you
they're going to have a problem I'm talk
Financial I'm not talking Financial when
I mean winning to me is uh uh like for
example right now Jennifer and I are
talking and she says hey babe kids are
learning Armenia right now yeah and I
love it okay they're coming in they're
talking to me in Armenian and my wife's
white and she cares about my kids
speaking Armenian and she says babe
should we have the kids learn fary next
or Assyria next uh which Community is
bigger I said babe it's not even a
question like Persian Community is
bigger but you know what I want the kids
to learn Assyrian okay so let them learn
Assyrian now if we winning to me is
Unified if we can go and bring our power
together our influence together and we
have a common Vision we've all agreed on
that we're going to now you can say from
the pulpit now you can say from your
podcast now this person can say
from their military base now that guy
can say it from the comedy stage now
this guy can say it from a movie that
guy can say it from an acceptance speech
this guy can say it from this place from
business it doesn't matter we have to
collectively bring all our resources to
tell the world here's what we're doing
yeah get the backing of it and then use
whatever resources we can bring to the
table to go win winning will be we got
land there's representation here's how
it's being protected here's what we're
going to be doing that's what I mean by
it I think it's fair to say it's better
if ass syrians get a country right we
would like to have our own land abely
absolutely that would be an element of
winning I remember back in in 2000 I I
went with my I call my Earthly mother
and may God Rest her soul in peace she
she moved on this year in in June so um
and may God have have mercy on all the
all all the Departed Souls we went to
Iran because um from my mother's side U
um there is there is one side which is
which is from Iran so we went to
and we visited the villages around and
we went to this Village called satl now
in satl we were walking and those
beautiful uh little Villages alleys and
then people were standing just outside
and I heard this family speaking in
Assyrian and they greeted Us in
Assyrian please do come in you know the
very um hospitable uh people so and then
we walked further and then another
family again spoke in Assyrian and
another family in Assyrian I was still
very young and then for the first time
ever it hit me so beautifully and I said
I asked a question uh I said how come
all these people speak Assyrian he said
well the entire Village are Assyrian
speaking people they're all Assyrians it
felt at home honestly I must say it felt
at home I was so so happy so so happy
because I've never experienced that ever
ever ever before imagine all your
neighbors are aans it's wonderful it's
beautiful but Above All In imagine this
neighbor has the love of God and the
fear of God what we are lacking dear
Patrick is
leadership in our
nation is
leadership and as George uh sort of
address this who is in charge this is
the problem of
us
we if someone comes and says let's let's
elect this person to be the spokesperson
of the entire Assyrian Nation they will
say well how come you selected this one
how come not that one or me why is this
why is he from this tribe this is a
stranger again I've I've witnessed this
I've seen this I've lived this tribal
influence whether we like it or not is a
reality and it's a haunting reality I
must say even within the church Circle
even within the church Circle if I am if
the majority are from this particular
tribal background they have to rule and
if someone else who is more worthy maybe
he is more qualified not worthy more
qualified to be in that position but he
is not from that tribe which is the
majority in that particular Church they
will never ever give him that
opportunity to take that leadership role
where he could have done wonders and
miracles if he had been appointed there
tribal influence unfortunately is a
hindrance and a big one in our so now so
that's exactly where I was trying to get
to I'm I'm trying to find out what is uh
uh hindering so maybe one of them could
be tribal influence that within that
small tribe however big it may be
somebody's at the top and they don't
want to relinquish or give up their
power and authority and influence that
they have over their people that's a
weakness that's that's a bit of a
weakness but think about it pet do do
you think right now if right now they
just said and I'm just I'm just naming a
name George we're going to have George
finally because we talked about it here
we we put all the pieces in order we're
going to have George speak for the
Syrian people we need a leader and we're
going to go around George it would never
they're just like the bishop said
they're going to eat him alive this
side's going to say this this side's
going to say that it's almost as if and
I've heard this before Bishop I'm pretty
sure you have and you have too that just
Assyrians were just in the Bible were
just not meant to be here we're not you
know we're doomed and it's written that
we're not supposed to have a land and
we're not supposed to have anything
that's what people are going to say and
that's exactly we're going to do I have
hope I have faith in God I'm not as deep
in the scriptures as you guys are but
it's like it's like and you've taught me
more than any body not not to be
hopeless you know have faith there's
there there is a chance but with the way
that Assyrians are with that that tribal
that anger of that thing it it it's
almost to me it's like impossible to
think that that they'll pick one to do
it I think I think this isn't sequencing
is what I'm thinking uh if done in the
right sequence the first sequence is
bring up the conversation okay then let
small communities all talk to each other
tonight during dinner Hey Dad why do you
think thisy hey Mom why do you think
this hey bro why do you think this hey
let me think these guys were talking
about the Ser they said what do you
think about what he said what do you
okay so that's step number one let them
have the conversation but then two is if
if there is somebody selling what makes
the Assyrian blood unique and you're
selling that over and over and over
again then what do that create that
creates Pride then when there is pride
and that happens through affirmations
and of selling the dream constantly of
why you need to have pride in your
background then there needs to be a
meeting then that meeting needs to be
trying to find a way to hey let's unify
let's simplify let's mult multiply Works
in business it works in religion it
works in media it works in YouTube unify
everybody let's simplify message and
let's go multiply and tell everybody
else about it and what's the vision
here's a vision this is what we're doing
great ready boom boom boom break let's
go boom and then everyone is selling
that and collectively people can come
together and fight for something but the
idea of saying you
know it'll never happen I don't know
about this I don't know about that well
then guess what you keep saying that
you're right it's not going to happen
but for me I'd like to see uh uh the the
first conversation starts off with the
uncomfortable conversation of why are we
here and then let's see where we go from
there you know um sorry no please dear
Patrick I
believe when we when I mentioned earlier
that we lacking leadership like for
example if a father at home the father
needs to be the servant of that
household he he cannot be the dictator
of that household he needs to lead by
example how do I teach my children to be
faithful to be um uh you know morally
sound and all that I need to lead by
example the problem with us as Assyrians
we have Miss we lack that trust of that
leadership maybe there has come leaders
in the past but there was no leading by
example that's why that trust is also
broken you see um as I said we are a
broken re Nation we are shattered we are
scattered everywhere recently we just
visited three uh different countries
turkey Lebanon and Syria and we've met a
lot of Assyrian people and these three
countries that was back in September of
this
year um when we went to this particular
City the person whom we have been
dealing with uh back in Sydney and you
know sending whatever support we could
send by the grace of the Lord um when he
greeted us at the airport he said Bishop
in you are the first Bishop in 100 years
to enter the city we have never seen a
bishop ever coming to the city and just
saying hello we're not seeking financial
support we're not saying U so and so
leader please bring us money we need
money no we we need love we need a
leader that is thinking of us we need a
leader that is coming to us whether I am
in the street whether wherever I am I
want to see my leader to be hands on I
want to see my leader walking the
streets barefooted I want to see my
leader leading me in that this is what
we are lacking now for a leader to go
there for the first time in 100 years
that is
disastrous that is
disastrous all glory to the Lord Jesus
if there is a sinner it is me but my
heart is broken is shattered as a
Christian Assyrian and I will say
Christian Assyrian because the only time
I will be a proud Christian when Christ
is the crown of my glory this is the
dilemma I'm sorry but this is the truth
and I'm not sorry for it we need to come
back to to Jesus Christ because who sent
me to that City it was the Lord Jesus
who reminded me of my Brethren's that
are suffering it was the Lord Jesus who
made me to walk the distance it was the
Lord not me not my Earthly father not my
Earthly mother it is Jesus Christ of
Nazareth who said to me go and seek
those who are missing forgotten
Afflicted Left Behind it's the Lord Lord
we are missing this in our leadership
roles the fear of the Lord is the
beginning to
wisdom that's the Aramaic
language which it can be translated as
well the
foundation the
foundation uh of wisdom is the fear of
the Lord because the beginning here
means the
foundation no now as a leader you need
to be the foundation but guess what the
foundation is the one that carries the
entire structure the foundation is the
one that is
unseen you see when you look at a house
when you look at a beautiful tree you'll
stand and contemplate of that tree and
you say what a beautiful tree look at
the branches look at the leaves look at
the look at the fruits but all this
beauty was made possible by the hidden
Roots underneath that ground it is the
roots and this is why St Paul puts it so
beautifully he says children no matter
how smart how wise you are and
successful do not forget you are the
fruits and the fruits do not carry the
tree it is the roots who are the parents
who carry this tree again coming back as
George mentioned who is in charge and
whoever is in charge need be hidden I.E
self-denial the problem with our
leadership whether as a nation or as a
church the moment we sent on that Throne
we think we are Augustus Caesar listen
my dear friend that Throne of being a
patriarch of being a bishop that Throne
is the Throne of being the servant of
all not the leader of all in the sense
of controlling the problem with our
nation we do not have enough humble
leaders we do not have enough
God-fearing leaders I'm not saying we
don't entirely no we do but there is not
enough of them and unfortunately
this is the Dilemma of our
people um Assyrian people I have to be
honest Assyrian people are very
kind-hearted people are very generous
people they they they sacrifice when we
ask for help they come out and even if
they don't have they'll do their
ultimate best to give very generous
people this is in our blood in our
DNA compared to other nationalities with
all L respect I've seen it very generous
people but they lack trust in their
leadership um beautifully
said
um I want to bring it back to Judaism
because they have a great nation right
now it's very strong but before remember
even before King David was the king they
kept falling I mean think about when
Moses it was supposed to take two weeks
but it took 40 years because what
happened is the people left God's will
they said hey I know you gave us the
example I know you gave us the
Commandments but we'd rather worship
this rock um so the reason why me and
him are standing saying first comes our
relationship with God because we are
God's people right if we are as certain
as the first things that we say is oh we
are we speak the language Jesus Christ
spoke all of our claims is having to do
with Christ then we better act
accordingly because we can't
misrepresent him then he can't as the
CEO he doesn't even want to step in
because he's like you guys are
representing me the wrong way that's one
two I'm very new I'm the youngest one
here and I I it's very troubling when I
speak because I don't have uh I might
have wisdom from the gospel but I don't
have time and I think a lot of time is
necessary because you make the mistakes
you learn from them but the one thing
that I've learned is I disagree with you
I'm going this direction and I'm
bringing everybody with me I disagree
with you Pat I'm taking everything that
you taught me and you gave me and you
loved me I'm bringing it this way that's
only the devil only the devil wants to
tear something up if you brought me this
uh platform and it's the moment that I
have power and I use it to beat you over
the head with it and leave that's an
evil move so if I was um that had Dar or
anything represented in my church what I
realize is this when you read the
scripture Jesus is moving around and
he's moving he's Moon walking past the
Pharisees and the and the scholar
holders why because he's not offending
and he's not going against them he's
playing by their rules and still
managing to destroy them every day they
wake up what did Jesus do today did he
do something that we could Stone him
with and he Moonwalks past them because
he's not offending and he's not
separating he's just leading with
example so if I was a man that's in the
church and I'm noticing that it's wrong
I'm not going to go say hey gather
gather today we're going to be against
them we need to show them that they're
wrong let's take everybody take your
families take your money let's break
this house let's go over here or we
could ready for this when the king
wanted to Stone Jesus he couldn't
because the people saw him as a prophet
they were scared of the people not the
soldiers they were scared of their libba
more than they were of their
weapons they were scared they thought
John the Baptist came back to life they
were paralyzed amen so what happened is
the power got removed from the people it
went to DAR and people started getting
scared of the man on the pulpit versus
the man in charge but if we have four
microphones we have a man who's with DAR
we have a man who's Patrick M David we
have Vinnie we have all of these
powerful things we instead of separating
which I don't think anybody here is
doing this is just me speaking out loud
if we are going to take a step it's
first and foremost know who God is
second don't offend anybody lead with
example and third get the power back to
the people and not the Kings I think
it's mathematically impossible to choose
to do the impossible without a defending
people I think it's mathematically
impossible to choose
to unify thinking you need 100% of
people to be on the same page you don't
oh no no I just don't there's a
difference from trying to offend Patrick
versus I'm going to do this and if it
offends you I'm going to dust my feet
and leave no no no it's not what I'm
saying but what I'm saying is whenever
you want to do something big you and
this is not easy to do like what we're
talking about here is not an easy thing
to do we can we can transition I maybe
our children will do it but the
conversation started yeah I I agree but
I think I in in doing anything big
you're going to offend some people to
want to do that okay so George just this
is a question for you and I'm curious I
know what you're going to say about this
so Americans under 30 don't trust
religion okay uh this this study just
came out Young Americans particularly
gen Z and the young Millennials and
increasingly disaffiliating from
organized religion with up to 40% of
categorizing themselves as nuns a term
encompassing atheist agnostic and those
no specific religious affiliation many
of these young adults prefer to Identity
as nothing in particular reflecting
their reluctance to align with a defined
religious worldview this formative
distrust is attributed to the experience
of growing up during periods of
political turmoil where institutions and
processes were increasingly criticized
and question factors contributing to
this
dissatisfaction uh this
affiliation from organized religions
amongst young adults include uh evolving
views on the issues like abortion lgbtq
acceptance and the role of women in
churches okay so that's that part now
having said this you were one of the
three characters on the impulsive
podcast it's yourself Mike and uh uh
Logan Paul right and it's the three of
you and you guys were there was a very
good combination between the three of
you I didn't know you were a Syrian
until somebody said you know George enko
is a Syrian I'm like oh he just on my
way that's cool and he started talking
about your faith I think it was July 19
2020 2021
uh uh you uh are having a conversation
let me see if this is the one no let me
get the exact dates on this hang on one
second here you go yeah in August of
2020 you're on uh the impulsor podcast
episode
206 uh which came under criticism after
the two got two heer debate Christian
values it came to a head with a
hypothetical regarding Hitler and the
potential of killing him if he came back
to life some guy was going back and he
said do you forgive everybody and I said
absolutely 100% he goes Hitler comes
back to life you had a chance to kill
him right now do you kill him I go no
jenko explained Hitler at the end of the
day was such a powerful speaker so
motivating and so strong in the
situation when I took this man anybody
like this man I just don't you know
flesh anyways you guys go back and forth
those comments were met with laughter
from Logan Paul okay who was taken back
by how ludicrous they were many fans
downvoted the video and voiced their
disappointment and Paul's
disrespectful reply Logan Paul addressed
the back lash on the next episode of
impulsive podcast where he said the
podcast was a place to debate Paul
believes that while he considers jenko a
good friend he will point out how insane
his opinion was now why do I bring this
up you are right now 30 years old when
this happened you were 27 years old this
whole article is about people under 30 I
don't know how many people have as much
influence over people under 30 as Logan
Paul maybe Mr Beast maybe a couple other
guy Mr Beast probably going to be number
one in that category but Logan's in that
category why do you
think you know young adults under the
age of 30 are not turned on by the idea
of believing in a God today and it's the
lowest number we've seen in a long time
in
America so much unpacked yeah please uh
so first um you
know that statistic of many uh people
going the wrong direction the first
statistic was ever given was in the goel
and he said many will go through the
Broadway and very few would go through
the correct way through uh what we
believe to be is Christ um and for you
to
really submit yourself to God you have
to get rid of your ego you have to die
yourself when you really meet the
Creator and you realize the separation
distance between God and you it's a very
humbling experience and it changes you
it changes everything about you it
changes the way you speak it changes the
way you interact with your enemies it
changes the way that you look at life
you value the the the things that you
didn't value before and then the things
you did value you look at them and you
laugh and you're like why did I even
value this stuff it changes your heart
um and in the scripture he always says
for those who have ears that want to
hear and those who have eyes that want
to see um what are you investing in
and when I grew up I I was blessed to be
in a home that's Christian but I never
really invested in it but once I
invested in it like your business you
fall in love with it you fall in love
with your craft you you absorb
everything into it and young people
don't want to be told what they can't do
young people don't want I can only have
sex with one girl oh wait wait wait hold
on it's wrong for me to want to go do
this and go to do this and I think what
happened is there's so many people
telling them what they shouldn't be
doing
and there's less examples of what love
is that's why I find Christ to be so
cool dude if you if you if you observe
from a historical standpoint what that
man was saying during the times that he
was saying in bro he he was out
outraging everyone was mad at this man
when they came up to me they're like hey
what's up with this and you divorcing
like we can't divorce people because we
don't like the way they cook and God's
like okay well then you're going to have
to give half of your
stuff people didn't know that Jesus was
standing up for women back then people
will go over here and be like you
believe in a chauvinistic religion and a
god like the person that shared the good
news was a prostitute the first person
that realized that Jesus woke from the
dead was a prostitute and she was the
one that went to deliver the news to the
disciples there's misinformation just
like in this country right now it's
divided because of
misinformation there's a lot of people
filling in junk in these young people's
hearts but then when they grow up to
grow old and they were like let me weigh
this out for a bit
let me see what's actually I think is
wrong what I think is actually right and
I think young people um are under attack
because of social media I me like why
would I want to get off the phone this
is giving me so much more than me
flipping through my Bible and I'm like I
I can't even understand this let me ask
you how much you think uh uh because if
you go back 20 years ago right we didn't
have these things here we didn't have
the smartphone we didn't have the social
so kids looked up to a pastor a priest
or whoever's on TV
today they look up to you know the
social media influencers a lot of these
younger guys who most of them are not
getting up they're talking about God or
they're not talking about faith because
if you do you probably would lose
followership you know you're like well
it's not cool it's a lot better if I do
this and if I do that and if I do this
this is a better way of me making money
why don't you think social media has
turned you know uh Logan Paul may be a
pastor in in a religion uh certain form
of a religion to young boys that are
looking up to somebody like him do you
think socials made some of these guys uh
in a way where they don't feel they can
talk about their faith and young kids
are looking at them saying that's my
hero instead of me looking up to God I
think that uh we live like kings now
everyone like legit like a a middle
class man lives better than what King
David lived like and I think that's why
God says I I judge your heart not your
actions your actions are meaningless
your actions are limited to your
accessibility how much money you have
how much power how much influence that's
why he judges your heart what are you
doing when you see and forgive me I'm
going to speak about diff like difficult
things if I but like we look at the
stuff that they're watching with
pornography and what they're fantasizing
about it's corrupted it's evil would
they do that in real life would they
cheat would they sleep with that married
woman or the woman who's stuck these are
all really like hard-hitting questions
yeah you can watch it on your iPad but
would you do that in real life you would
sleep with this man's wife when he's not
around and these people are doing what
they could when that door is locked and
that lotions next to them they'll do
whatever they want God knows they would
do that when the chance to come in front
of them and the opportunity was there
they would take it the internet just
gives you the opportunity to be wild and
out you could be whoever you want online
and you're protected and you have a
majority of people siding with you so I
don't believe this generation became
more evil because of the internet or the
phone I believe that they're accessible
to be who they really are so I think at
the end of the day phones or no phones
who they are deep in their hearts is who
God's watching them out to
be so then maybe flip it so why why are
influencers not turned on uh by by the
message that God and Christ provides why
are they not turned on by it you know
why is it that you know today why is
Andrew Tate whom you just went and sat
down with in Romania why is Andrew Tate
pretty smart guy this is a guy that's
very good at communicating telling
stories he's an alpha why is why is he a
Muslim why does he get up there and say
the argument for Muslim is a better
argument for Christians because Muslims
stand up for their faith while
Christians don't Muslims will defend
what they stand for but Christians don't
have the backbone that Muslims have why
why do you think a guy like that was
turned on to being a Muslim instead of
being a Christian I can't speak for
another man cuz I don't know his shoes
right I I don't know what he's done but
and if a man gives me his examples by
the people it's not a very good example
but if you're giving an example of why
you worship the god you worship and
these are the reasons why he's a real
God and why this this and this and that
then I I would be able to listen but for
you to judge my people for example we're
sitting here talking about Assyrians but
I love Assyrians and I think Assyrian
people are good now their track record
right now might not be the craziest but
that doesn't Define my people right
they're separated now
um uh I I had this in my mind and I
wanted to say but I want to make sure I
I word it perfectly
uh the first
person that I realized ran the Earth is
when Jesus was uh in the
wilderness and Lucifer came to him and
he goes hey man you worship me and
you'll get all this
stuff that is the story that's been told
for thousands of years the people on top
are not worshiping God they're
worshiping themselves and they're
worshiping the and everybody's looking
at it because Hollywood knows how to
edit it and make it look beautiful cuz
remember the angel that we saw that's
called Lucifer was the angel of
entertainment he was the Angel of Music
so long shot is this man's probably
using his skill sets to influence other
people but you have money you have
access you have power it gets old and it
rots up and it goes away and guess what
from your standpoint of standing here
with all of your success and I could go
through throw a rock at a homeless guy
you guys have the same grave and when
people really understand that their
decisions on Earth change because they
haven't been in your shoes they just
think that your shoes is easy and it's
fun and it's fast and it's sexy but they
haven't been in your shoes they haven't
seen the struggles that you've had the
choices you've made the sacrifices
you've made they see something on a
screen and they go I want bad girls and
money 100% that's my God okay but you
this is the craziest move Jesus did to
the people that didn't agree with him
okay go ahead bishari question for you
okay so you're you're very you won't
hold back during covid you were
everywhere you call that Australia you
call that America you call that fouchi
you call out anybody and everybody you
were not willing to you know cave to the
Mob and the establishment and people
found you to the average person you're
not a bishop Assyrian to the average
person you're the man that's SP speaks
the truth oh he is a Syrian I did not
know that right that's kind of how
you're known to most people around the
world why do you think you know just 50
60 years ago Christians there was four
times amount of Christians as Muslims
three to four times the amount of
Christians as Muslims now it's about one
to one okay it's a little shy of that um
Christians have 2.1 kids per woman
Muslims have
2.9 Muslims are out there you know God
forbid you say something about uh the
religion of Islam you will be destroyed
by not one or two they will come after
you if you say anything about them and
their faith why do you think the
Christian religion has hit a wall and
it's not growing at the levels that it
was I can give you the growth rate here
the population growth for Christianity
1.18% okay is what it is right now
Christianity
1.18% is what they have within it the
fastest growing one is 1.88%
Pentecostals then the next one is
evangelicals then at the you know you
got Catholics at the lowest one 093
Catholics are grow growing at the
lowest Islam on fire growing the way
they are the way it's going right now in
the next 30 Years you know majority of
Senate majority of house is going to be
Muslims why do you think Christians at
Flatline and Muslims are grown the way
they
are um the Lord Jesus did say when we
read in the Book of Revelation he said
my church and the end of times would
have walked away from me see when you
look at the uh Revelation Chapter 2 and
3 um talks about the U seven churches in
in Asia and begins with Ephesus and then
ends up with Le odia these names are all
of of Greek origin now it began with
Ephesus that was the first era the first
century which is the beloved one but it
ended up with the the rebellious one um
I believe nowadays the church in general
The Universal Church in general is not
seeking the true Messiah it has created
a a Christ that follows her instead of
her following him um there is so many
factors that are happening within
Christendom that's why it ended up being
maybe so weak in the face of um 2020
what was happening in the on a global
level all church
leaders maybe just a a few very few here
and there all of them agreed all of them
supported and all of all of them
encouraged their flock uh to adhere to
what was happening yet it was really um
very very clear um everything was
actually planned it was a planemic
instead of a pandemic but the problem is
the moment the church loses Christ the
church loses her power and authority
every everything comes from the Lord
Jesus
um if somebody says that the Lord Jesus
was uh was very loving very kind very
merciful um he was very very weak in
fact they dragged him the streets of
Jerusalem they kicked him punched him
bashed him and then they nailed him on
the cross fully naked uh that's to us is
very weak what kind of a God is that but
they do not understand the concept of
Love Of Love on the other hand if there
has been any
in the history of humanity that changed
the history of mankind is the one and
only Jesus Christ of Nazareth he is the
only one who changed the history of
mankind without carrying one sword or
one bullet he changed the world with
love love is foundational love is the
Supreme ethic if I if somebody talks
about my Lord Jesus uh in a in a
negative way and then I go on a rampage
on a riot and go on the streets and and
say how dare you talk about my Jesus I
don't believe this is a powerful way of
of expressing my faith because
Christianity we do not defend the faith
we do not defend Christ it is Christ who
defends us I don't we I don't need to
defend him I don't need to stand and say
this and that however however when I am
submissive to him when I am faithful and
loyal to him when I am trying my
heartest by his grace to be with him oh
no he will give me this might and this
power nothing nothing worries me nothing
can ever shake me or break me because
when you have Christ you've got nothing
to lose the problem with the church it
is weak because it is not reflecting the
true Messiah that's why it's weak why do
you think that is though why are they
not doing that why are they not because
because the
throne the throne we've sat on high
places and those Thrones are dangerous
they can change they can change minds
and hearts you see it was at the time of
the Lord Jesus history is repeating
itself once again when the Lord came he
went into the temple and that Temple was
his but what did he say he said my my
house is the House of Prayer but you
have turned it into a den of Thieves you
have turned it into a den of Thieves and
in fact he he spoke about the house
twice and one was in the Gospel of John
and the other one in Matthew and in John
that was his the beginning of his
ministry and in Matthew was the end of
his ministry in the beginning he said my
father's house uh is is the House of
Prayer but you've turned it into a
Marketplace buying and selling but when
he came to his house he said my house is
the House of Prayer but you've turned it
into a den of Thieves now what is a a
den of Thieves what is the house
associating to Jesus
Christ what is associated with Christ is
glory and what is associated with his
father is love that's why when it comes
to love there is buying and selling
because you will never buy something
that you do not love you will only buy
the things that you really love but when
it comes to the Lord Jesus it's to do
with glory and what is Christ Glory the
cross you know it takes it takes power
for someone to deny themselves a weak
person cannot deny himself or herself it
takes wisdom it takes power for me to
deny myself and and live for the one I
love Christ is the leading example in
this he died in order to say I I lived
for you Patrick and Vinnie and George
and me and all of us and the entire
world and for me to live for you
therefore I gave my life up for you to
say that this is the true love in this
no one can argue no one can fight maybe
I can force someone to love me but I
cannot do it freely forcefully and when
I force someone to love me the moment
they have the opportunity to attack me
rest assure they will never hesitate to
do so but the Lord wants people that
choose to be with him not forcefully be
with him Christ is totally different to
any other religious figure out there and
the Lord invited everyone to walk
through the noro gate he said the gate
is narrow and the way is difficult and
only few find it but this way leads to
eternal life but he said it only if you
find it so when you just see the
majority there quantity doesn't mean
anything it is the quality which Christ
is looking for the problem with the
church is seeking quantity not
quality it took one man to change the
the the history of mankind Jesus Christ
it took St Paul to change the people of
his era and generation after him God can
work with one to do his job I think I
think that's a
that's very uh the quantity versus
quality argument I totally agree and 300
they were very strong but they got
destroyed by a bigger Army and and
whatever Army that gets bigger is going
to have a bigger voice and able to
recruit more people let me let me kind
of give you sure uh one story this
Saturday uh I get back from uh La in
Vegas and uh I have a swim meat for
Dylan my youngest son and I'm sitting
there and I'm watching him do his thing
and this guy sitting next to me hey how
you doing good so you know tell me your
story what do you do I'm a pastor oh
very cool so what made you want to be a
pastor this this that okay great so so
what do you why do you think the
Christian Church isn't growing right now
what do you think it's flatlining why do
you think Mormons are growing why do you
think certain sects are growing but why
do you think the Christian church is not
growing in a you know Islam has grown
the way it is why I think the
congregations needs to get more
passionate about their faith I said
interesting so the congregation needs to
yeah I said got it okay I said who's
who's leading the charge who's doing the
inspiration who's doing the challenging
who's doing the expectation who's
selling high standards who's doing that
today uh there's not a billy gramp it's
a Joel Austin I don't see Joel Austin
doing it is gr is amazing Billy Graham
210 million people he was doing it when
he went to LA and gave a uh uh he was
preaching at rosebowl uh 2003 in
November where they made it a billy grah
day I was there three out of the four
days and I want to listen to him
you got to see him live three times
three out of four days so so what's the
so what's the you know what is the you
know a person from the pulpit that's
doing it by the way I've only had one
Pastor ever on my podcast and a preacher
only one whether it's priest Pastor
preacher whatever category you want
you're the only one so why is it I've
only had you I've interviewed a lot of
people over the last 10 years why are
you the only one because your messaging
is a message of high standards and it's
it's a attractive to a father like
myself that have four kids I think we've
gotten away from that message that is
not a message of the you know the
tolerant message it's okay it's okay
it's okay yes you know and then we went
back in for having a conversation
unfortunately I couldn't finish it
because I had to come back for dillan's
baseball party at the house but um what
what what do you think about that part
where the leaders of many of these
churches are caving to being too
tolerant and acceptance of everything
and let anybody in the pope just had a
group of uh uh transgenders over at the
uh uh what do you call it lunch like a
lunch and then he's saying hey you know
we need to be asking theologians to
demasculate the Catholic church he urges
religions to unite against environmental
Devastation a lot of these weird things
that he is saying which is a let's be
more tolerant let's be more tolerant
let's be more tolerant so do you think
that could be one of the reasons why the
church isn't grown the way that it used
to be absolutely um the Lord Jesus um if
we were to compare him to any other
religious figure I just want to come
back to this point where you said Islam
is growing and Christianity is not if we
were to compare even though there is no
comparison but let us compare them for a
moment uh with other religious figures
with all love and respect let's say um
islamism Buddhism Hinduism Shintoism all
the all the religions of the world and
all the the leaders of those religions
let's say the ultimate they could have
achieved in their life uh in relation to
humanity they would have probably
achieved the ultimate by changing a bad
person into a good person by bringing
some values morals and what whatever
they brought with so they would would
have changed a bad person into a good
person Jesus Christ of Nazareth all
glory to His holy name he did not come
to change a bad person into a good
person he came to change a dead person
into a living one in this there is no
comparison Jesus Christ Christ stands
Supreme alone and high up there Beyond
any other religious figure the problem
dear Patrick the problem of the church
leaders is one
thing the beginning the very beginning
with Christ a relationship with Christ
it begins with death he needs he said
carry my cross and follow me and this is
what I said I meant to say when he said
my house is the house of prayer and
you've turned it into Iden of Thieves
what's Associates associated with Christ
is glory and what is Christ Glory the
cross what is cross death what is death
self-denial this is the human dilemma we
cannot deny ourself why because I need
to give up on the things I love I want
to do I choose to do for me to give up
on them I cannot it's a struggle but the
Lord says unless I live in you and and
no no longer is you you cannot make it
when the church
leader puts himself on the throne and
make himself seen to the congregation
and to the faithfuls he's lost himself
he's lost the flock with him he needs to
reflect Christ to the congregation not
himself a leader that makes followers
love him not Christ is a failure but the
leader that makes the followers love
Christ through him that that is a
successful leader today leaders are
sitting on those Thrones and by the way
that Throne is Christ's it's not mine
all of us were we were in the Pix field
who brought me out of that PX field who
brought me out of the filth of the world
and the Temptation Of The World the
blood of the Lamb of God who was shed on
Calvary now when I look at the cross
that is the power of God this is the
ultimate ultimate love when I give my
life for the one I love when I give my
life life for the one I love and we see
this love Illustrated in a in a very
sort of small level at Parenthood level
parents if I ask a father or a mother
why are you working so hard what are you
trying to do I want I'm running I'm
doing this I'm working 24/7 non-stop
because I want to provide a good future
for my children I want them to be
healthy I want them to be prosperous
successful I am devoting my time and
sacrificing that time which is life for
my children for their well-being why are
you doing this is this weakness no this
is the heart of strength and power when
you give your life for the one you love
the problem with the church the moment
the leader is seen not
Christ there is no power in that leader
there is no power in that church the
current of the world will wash your away
and this is what we're seeing you know
when when plandemic
hit I always say this I always say this
I'm not judging if anything I'm judging
myself I'm not judging God is the judge
but it hurts me so deeply and and so
profoundly the Lord Jesus has been
crying out from Calvary on the cross for
over, 1600 years for the church to be
United in him for the church to be
United in him you see all these
different factions Catholics Orthodoxy
or Eastern Oriental you see an
Protestant branches thousands of
branches in there the Lord is saying
unite unite unite till this very moment
we haven't put a smile on the Lord's
face by uniting in his name but when the
vaccine came when the plandemic came all
church leaders spoke the same language
amazing we did not unite for Christ but
we we United for Satan now to me Christ
is missing Christ is
missing you know certain people came out
and spoke about about what was happening
in the world I know their backgrounds it
doesn't take a genius to figure out who
these people are and their backgrounds
are how come like someone in this
influential position who is well
educated and well informed and embedded
in scriptures and other and and other
fields you do not know where this is
coming from you do not know but for you
to be silent and not only silent I wish
they were silent but they were
supportive and encouraging and standing
on that pulpit and encouraging the flock
to follow suit for me this is total
denial of Jesus Christ and the making
and that's why Satan has engulfed the
churches and took it away to hell um I
love when you speak man I just just want
to let you know and also you're playing
that it's like you have this sauce with
you you're like like you're like humble
and meek but then also you got that like
righteous sword we have to be I love it
I love it I was reading uh Mark
yesterday I brought this up twice cuz I
was studying because I felt like for
some reason something in Mark was going
to be popping up and it did uh Jesus
Takes a few disciples up to the top to
meet Moses and Elijah and they're
freaking out man they they're messing up
in the presence of God and uh the
prophets they're messing up they're like
we'll stay here we'll build this we'll
do this they miss the mark and then the
other disciples that are not even
involved in this are down there and then
when Jesus comes back down he goes hey
what's up with this uh I'm paraphrasing
to have fun what's up with this nonsense
what are you guys saying down here and
they're like well we're saying that
disciple can't cast out demons and I'm a
little bit better than this disciple and
this discip and he goes hey hey hey
whoever wants to be first will be last
and whoever is last will be first amen
and then right after Jesus gets
crucified uh and actually during it
Peter the the disciple the one that
everybody believes was built on first
thing he goes I'm going to give you the
keys to heaven and then he goes Satan
get behind me immediately God
compliments him and then he falls short
because he's like God you don't need to
get crucified and then after the
crucifixion uh the disciples won they
got scared they ran away doubting Tom
didn't get his name until he made him
put his finger through through his hand
these are the disciples that are
consistently missing the mark and what
I'm just trying to prove is that no
one's perfect besides Christ but there's
very very broken people that are doing
the wrong things but they're still doing
the will of God because God doesn't use
Perfect People for his will he used
broken people for his will I mean even
King David was a shepherd's boy I've
heard all of these stories guys I mean
you're talking to a guy that's been you
know I'm not uh you know uh what I'm
asking is a different kind of a question
I'm asking
what is what is so much more attractive
to the Youth of the the you know Muslim
religion that's being attractive to them
that is getting their
attention than Christianity what what is
it from the way it's being presented
that that is Fallen more on them to say
you know these guys seem to be more
serious about it than those guys those
guys seem to be winging it Christians
they'll they'll all say the right things
but and I'm not talking about you I'm
talking about the majority is yeah but
those guys seem like they're True
Believers they're 100% in it why is that
more attractive and why is it grown the
way that it is they were far behind it's
fourth quarter we have a three four
touchdown lead and then boom tie game I
got an idea when when I talk to you you
you're very uh uh number oriented right
you're like you want the Army yeah I
feel like you're uh your everything
everything about my life so listen yeah
I was in LA this last week I did four
podcasts uh five podcasts I don't know
how many I did I did a few of them so I
was with Bradley Martin on uh Thursday
phenomenal conversation very different
he's great out his Dr then I was with DJ
Vlad who interviews hip-hop guys you
know and we had a great time okay six
million Subs great conversation then I
was with Lewis house and Lewis house
this the first time anyone's ever
interviewed me where I break down crying
and the question is like what question
would make you cry
the only thing that made me cry is the
conversation about God my entire life is
about how how much grace he's had and
how much has changed my life my
confidence and whatever Swagger that
people think I have it it's only coming
from one place Amen period there is no
other place that's coming from having
said that he's wired me in a different
way than maybe he's wired you or anybody
else I I look at the world in a
different
sense um I think generals typically
think strategy and they think about how
to win war and I think there's a if
there if you subscribe to the thought
that there's a SP spiritual warfare
going on and you're just going to go
there and be Whimsical about it you're
going to lose and you're going to get
destroyed you're going to have to be I
don't think Jesus said hey you know just
have faith and I'm going to pay your
bills just have faith and you guys going
to know I think he's going to say hey
like I I subscribe a big part of my life
was pray as if it's up to God but work
like it's up to you and I want to know
what I can do about it I'm already part
of the faith side I'm there I want to
know what I can do to spread the message
and as well as on top of that to see why
why other messages are being received
stronger in a way that's getting people
to say you know what I'm kind of kind of
connecting with you kind of connecting
with this I give you an idea like Bill
Mah right now comes out in TMZ story
Bill Maher says be aware of Christian
nationalism okay there's a lot of
interesting Bill Maher says and sometime
he just comes out but if there's one
thing about Bill Mah he's going to tell
you what he's thinking about okay so
Bill Mah loves the Christmas season
exmas not Christmas exmas season cuz
it's fun you know but he's alarmed at
all these people who embrace the
religious element to point they want to
shove it down everyone else's Thro the
real time uh host launched on the
growing number of Republicans now led by
freshly Meed Speaker of the House Mike
Johnson who want to turn America into
Christian State although Johnson and
many other Republicans have promoted
official religion to the US bill notes
that they've forgotten about the whole
separation of church and state you know
and then he goes into saying all these
other thing you know bber says I'm tired
of this separation of church and state
junk seems pretty basic the country was
founded on the under freedom of religion
it's ingrained in our constitution first
up on the amendment roster yet an
alarming number of Republicans are
hellbent on breaking that wall
separation of church and state you know
so in America like w you know what are
you guys talking about man this
Christmas I just want to have fun don't
put this pressure on me and doing all
this other St it's like but imagine you
did that with a different religion
imagine you took their holidays you're
like yeah we don't want to do that with
your God but we're going to make it X
like imagine putting X over anything
Muhammad did they would outrage they
would burn down what you did it's
disrespectful no one should ever do that
because it's written it's already
written 2,000 years ago God said this is
what's going to happen and I think what
you're having a hard time doing is
swallowing the fact that God said this
is how it's going to happen there's
going to be less of us and during the
end time there's going to be a lot more
selfish people doing selfies doing
things that they want to do a lot more
people have a lot more access a lot more
power it is written this way regardless
of we all stood up high gave up all your
money gave up all your power gave up all
your throne it is written it's done
there's nothing we can do about it but
we could do is give people the good news
and if there's a building on fire
instead of you being like there's 5,000
people in there they're dying there's
only 4,000 people no no no you're your
your eyes should be locked in on saving
as many people as your hands can and
your hands have the ability to reach
Millions so we shouldn't really be
sitting here stressed about who's
walking away from us but we should be
catering to the people that are here
with us I I don't do a lot of stress in
my life I have a very peaceful life you
seem stressed but but but but I will say
as a person that is always thinking
about a from the standpoint of a
leadership's lens you know I want to
know why a message is not resonating
with an audience that it is could it be
the fact that there's not somebody
that's uh uh you know the youth is not
attracted to it why not it's not like
others are because again to me Mormons
are growing exponentially they have a
lot of pride in what they stand for
they're they're very loud about it
they're very United about it they're
very you
know Collective about it and they they
protect each other if somebody's doing
something I got your back what business
are you I got your back what are you
doing with this we got you what you got
going on we got you right Muslims are
the same
way and to me on the Christian side it's
kind of like a little bit the Assyrian
side it's kind of like hey you know do
your thing and all this other stuff and
there there's a there's a bit of a in my
opinion the standards being dropped and
compromising too much yeah and when
you're talking about if you put x with
Muslim and all this stuff you couldn't
do that right so that's the part where I
see a little bit of the standards of not
being proud and being a little bit
apologetic to kind of bring It up and
God forbid if somebody sees me I may be
judged and all this stuff but who's the
first that are crucified you got to
remember this right so you're saying
that like people are only giving half
the news but let me give you an example
if you had children and your son's like
this is the news and some dude just ran
up and just punched him broke his face
kicked his ribs in the next guy's going
to be like okay well this is some of the
news you know what I mean because they
don't want to get crucified I think
everybody else who has their opinion on
what their God is or what their
situation is or who they identify as or
what they believe it's supported but as
soon as you bring up Jesus Christ you
get nailed man you get
crucified so it's very it's very
stressful for somebody to be like hey by
the way this is all the good stuff and
then when it comes down to the part
where you know you're this is the last
guy who brought this up got beat up it's
terrifying you're shaking because some
people don't want to get killed or
murdered because remember Jesus said and
this is a really crucial thing
especially nowadays we're dealing with
this just because you didn't murder a
man with his Cold Blood didn't mean that
it's not the same when you murder his
character and people are murdering
people's characters minute by minute
second by second unpack that so let me
an example you did so much good for your
your uh Community but then I'm an
Assyrian man I go into my community I'm
like yeah Patrick all he does is talk
about himself blah blah blah this is
that he doesn't even care about the
Assyrian people he does this now as an
Al they look at me they go well you know
George works with them and he and he's
with them so he knows so then they run
to the other people now all these other
people like you wouldn't believe what
George said he said and he was with a
man with a a cloth so you're murdering
their character agree I fully agree with
that being one of them I fully agree
that's one of them character
assassination fully yes go you were
going to say something um Christianity
is not going to resonate in the 21st
century with uh a lot of people of the
21st century for one reason but I that's
one side of the story if if I if I have
the time I want to share the other side
one is there are three kind of cultures
if we speak about cultures no more no l
is there is the theonomous culture there
is theonomous culture and there is the
autonomous culture these are all Greek
names Theos means god noos law so Theos
law God's law culture and there is hros
another uh law culture and there is the
autonomous self law culture if we were
to ask this question to the human race
of the 21st century which out of these
three cultures is the 21st century
definitely would be the third one
autonomous culture it is a self-driven
culture it's all about me me me me me
and the Lord Jesus comes says it's all
about Christ not you you need to deny
yourself in order for Christ to live in
you because this is the concept of love
the problem and with all of respect in
Islam the concept of love in
Christianity has got nothing to do with
the concept of love in Islam totally
different what do you mean by that now
because Islam and other are called
religions now when you invoke the name
religion automatically you are invoking
a set of rules guidelines laws and
regulations you go to Islam you got to
Buddhism Hinduism and all of them they
will tell you if you wish to end up in a
nice place you need to do this and this
and this and this it's all about you you
need to do it when you come to
Christianity John 15:5 the Lord Jesus
says it and plays the foundation so so
you know clearly and says without me you
cannot do anything so now when you come
and you need you have to do this you
have to do this and this and this to get
somewhere in Christianity it's not a
religion in the sense of a religion
because it's a belief in a person why
because when you speak about love love
cannot be found in law it can only be
found in a person with another person in
a relationship I cannot love law because
love says if if you break the law the
law will break you but when I came to
the Lord Jesus he said accept me in your
life and let me do all the good things
which God wants you to do let me do them
through you and with you so now when
people come and ask me like Christians
especially youth um I say to them you
don't have to go to church who told you
you have to go to church who told you
you have to pray who told you you have
to read the Holy Bible who told you you
have to fast they got a shock they go
back and change color oh that's coming
from a bishop really they feel good at
at the beginning because it's a relief
oh I don't have to thank God I'm going
to go and tell my mom and dad get off my
case don't ever force me to go to church
and don't tell me you have to go to
church the bishop the good-look bishop
said don't go to church so now um but
then I say to them I'll ask you this and
be honest do you love the Lord Jesus
if you're going to say yes then if you
love him you have to go to church if you
love him you have to read the Holy Bible
if you love him you have to pray you
have to fast if you love him so with an
autonomous with a with a an aut a
self-driven culture autonomous culture
it is very difficult to give up on me in
order to live for Christ that's one side
on the other side again we come back to
the Church of the 21st Century it is Le
oia the final stage of the church the
Lord prophesied two over 2,000 years ago
and said at the end my church would have
gone against me it's a rebellious church
and why it's a rebellious church because
again today it's a self-driven culture
even in the church even in the
leadership of the church everybody is
seeking their own throne their own glory
and their own power um I I when I when I
want to be sent to a church please send
me where there is a big congregation I
don't want to go to a little village
with only a couple of families there I
wanton be seen But I want to be in a
church where there is hundreds and
millions of people that come to that
church I with this I feel I'm powerful I
am in charge but that is not
Christianity that is not Christ himself
but let me say this dear Patrick the
Christ I came to know through his
grace I'll die for him any second I do
not give one p with all love and respect
no matter what happens because the
Christ that came and revealed himself to
this piece of
rck is the only one he is my king my
Lord my God my savior My Redeemer
forever and I will stand and speak the
truth let the whole world hate me I do
not care with love and humility I say
this I do not care you know why because
I didn't come for people to love me I
came for Christ to be pleased with me
and says this is my son in whom I am
well pleased come and inherit the
kingdom of of your father which was
prepared for you before the the creation
of the world now the issue is when I
come to Christ and by his grace I give
my life to him when he engulfs when he
takes over when he rules and Reigns over
my life I fear nothing you know why
because the moment I don't have anything
worldly materialistically I don't fear
to lose anything when I have nothing I
have fear of nothing because when I have
Christ I have everything but the issue
with Christ it is not materialistic it's
spiritual yeah it is love now love is
the Supreme ethic I ask an atheist a
Muslim a Buddhist a Hindu any human
being do you want to be loved everybody
will say yes you know even when you look
at the at the serial uh Killers even
when you look at the at the big drug
addicts and and and drug dealers if you
trace their life all the way back back
to Childhood I can show you a huge
percentage they will lacking love at
their childhood that's why they ender up
who they ender up it is the love that
forms and shapes and molds a human being
it is that love that never fails it is
that love that never dies Christ is
calling us to love him he is not calling
us to follow a set of rules guidelines
and regulations and let me say this to
all the religions of the world you're
talking about you must fast and you must
do this and you must you do your
penances and whatever you have to do let
me say this to enter in the presence of
God who can do what God wants who can
fulfill the fullness of the law of God
we are nowhere near that Perfection to
do and abide by what God does he showed
that in the Old Testament the Israelite
Nations they failed him from the word go
till the very end but he is is the never
failing God his Mercy that carries us
all of us as humans regardless whether
we are Christians or not so when those
religions out there with all love and
respect they talk about laws I'll ask
them are you fulfilling that law of
course not you're falling very short of
that law so don't tell me you have to do
this where you are failing as a leader
your Prophet failed those laws your own
Prophet failed them who Muhammad and all
the other leaders such a reporter move
and the and the very reason why Muhammad
fa because he's dead their book says
that but their book also says about my
Messi even though the ISA in the Quran
is not the Christ of the Holy Bible
totally separate people with we cannot
claim something that is not truthful I
know truth hurts I'm not offending
people I'm speaking the truth and if it
offends you I'm really sorry not I'm not
sorry for that but let me tell you one
thing your book says that ASA son of
Mary went up to heaven alive and he will
come come back to judge the dead and the
living if I ask a Muslim who judges they
will say God well you're telling me this
Prophet will judge so which is which has
the prophet taken the role of God has
God gone on vacation and he's come and
take his position no but Isa is the
living Messiah even their book says I
speak Arabic I read Arabic I'm fluent in
Arabic when they
say buta son of Mary Jesus of Mary is
the word of God and the spirit of God
now let me ask you my dear Muslim if
you're claiming Isa is a prophet then
how come all the other prophets which
you believe in you believe in Moses you
believe in Isa you believe in all the
prophets of the Old Testament how come
none of the Old Testament prophets were
referred to as the word of God except
Isa why how come all the prophets and
every single human being on the face of
this planet was born of an Earthly
father and an Earthly mother yet Jesus
Son of Mary was born in a virginal birth
through a virginal birth he has an
Earthly mother but has no earthly father
for his Father Who Art in Heaven why
this raises question marks how come this
man is different his birth is different
his life is different even his end is
different he went up
alive and he will come back to judge
because he is different that's the whole
story he is different my dear friend you
need to come and seek the true God with
an open mind open heart don't be fanatic
about your faith and I say this even to
the Christians the moment we become
Fanatics about our Christian faith we've
lost Christ we've lost the true
reflection of Christ and you may say
well I'm a bishop I'm Different maybe to
some Christians that live in this
blessed country of America who are from
a Protestant Branch I I come dressed up
like a ninja turtle I say I call myself
a walking tent but how come how come a
Protestant how come other Christians how
come a Muslim how come a Buddhist how
come an atheist is listening to this
good looking Bishop why because the day
you and I dear Patrick and all of us the
day we give our life to Christ surrender
to him and say Lord it is no longer I
but you I know I'm weak I'll fall short
I'll drift away but please Lord even
when I miss out even when I walk away
from you I'm asking you now before it
happens when it happens Lord remember
this moment when I called and I cried
out to you Lord have mercy on me I The
Sinner son of David have mercy on me
when I pray when I beg him when I cry
out to him even if I fall short he never
fails because he is the Living God who
was revealed in the flesh he is the
logos the Alpha and the Omega the
beginning and the end he is the way the
truth and the life and there is no one
else when Jesus Christ engulfs you and
you surrender to him and he takes over
you have no fear because Jesus fears no
one if they say Jesus was weak excuse me
who said to to Herod go and tell that
fox who stood who stood in front of
authorities and called them the sons of
the snake who said that it was Jesus of
Nazareth is that weakness no that is
mightiness and Power in its core why he
was so powerful and blunt because his
father was him he gave his life I'm
talking about Jesus the man because the
Son of God is God but the son of man the
perfect Lamb of God the perfect man this
man was Fearless why because when this
man gave his entire life to God you fear
nothing you fear no one because when God
is with you who can be against you let
me I'll finish off with this Jesus
Christ I not only believe in him dear
Patrick I know him look I'm a sinner I'm
the weakest ever believe you me I'm
talking with my head placed under the
sandals of the Lord if he allows me
because his sandals are more pure than
me but I say this with absolute humility
the Lord Jesus revealed himself to this
piece of wreck I don't speak about Jesus
just because I believe I'm a Christian
or I dress up in this cloth or I have
read the Bible which I have no I believe
in the Lord and I know the Lord he is 6'
one long face tan skin greenish eyes
browny crispy hair split in the middle
all the way to the shoulders with a very
short bead and after
2023 years he is still 33 years of age
and kicking baby he is the king of kings
and the Lord of lords yesterday he is
today he is and forever more he is he is
the Never Ever Changing God who was
revealed in the flesh over 2,000 years
ago and let me say this to the whole
world yes he came over 2,000 years
through a virginal B birth from our holy
mother Mary and at at he and he was
crucified not he was sent up to heaven
no he was crucified he died in the flesh
on the cross and he was buried but rose
from the dead on the third day ascended
to heaven and he's been sitting there at
the right hand of the father over 2,000
years ago and he will come back again to
J the dead and the living because he's
not just a prophet for he is God
revealed in the flesh this is the Jesus
I talk about that's why I fear no one I
fear nothing I'm not here for people to
love me I'm here for Jesus to be pleased
with this vessel that he uses for his
glory and His glory only he has showed
me heaven and hell and let me say this
with love and
humility when you go to heaven I can
assure you I can assure you not because
I'm a Christian not because I'm a bishop
not because I believe in Jesus Christ
but I can show you and Heaven you
Muhammad will not greet you Buddha will
not greet you Krishna will not greet you
because they will not it was it will be
only one who is the way the truth and
the life it will be Jesus Christ of
Nazareth who died for you and me I'm
inviting you to accept Jesus as Lord and
savior because there is no other way if
we don't have him we are doomed forever
for in him eternal life Lies when you go
to heaven and you meet Jesus face to
face Patrick you come back to earth who
cares about a president about Anthony
fouchi CLA Schwab George Soros and the
likes who cares with all love and
respect because when I meet Jesus I see
everyone a piece of dust what can a man
do to me oh they can kill me welcome
death I thank the Lord for death because
the death became that vehicle that took
me to my sweetheart Jesus Christ and
then I can say I can see him face to
face no more through a mirror no more
through a maze no more through a dream
but I'm seeing him really face to face
thank you thank you thank you Lord for
allowing me to be killed for your sake
so if they want to kill me I'm here this
face once you see it you can never miss
it my dear so I fear nothing for Jesus
Christ is the only God not because I'm a
Christian forget about
Christianity Focus On Christ just like
um Mahatma Gandhi when the British ruled
and and Enslaved the the Indians he
looked at the crucified the picture of
the of the crucified Jesus he said you
know what take away the Christians but
give me the Christ because Christ
wouldn't have done what these Christians
would have done today Christianity and
Christians are not reflecting the true
Christ but the moment any Christian
reflects the true Christ you draw the
whole world to you why don't we look at
that as I mentioned all glory to the
Lord how come this oddl looking person
in America with this outfit how come
people are listening to him because when
you let Christ speaks oh the Holy Spirit
can penetrate any heart and any mind and
any Soul no one can stop God for he is
the supreme authority you know I would
say I think the only that was powerful
um when you say fouchi and CLA Schwab
they would probably want to know if
everybody in heaven is vaccinated that's
what they would want to that's number
one it's very important it's very very
they are vaccinated by the blood of the
Lamb of God this is the end he has bars
on you guys he does I could believe you
want to know if if you know everyone's
vaccinated to make sure they're safe it
would be very important for everyone to
be wearing masks in heaven no they will
not shut this mouth with a mask let me
tell you my dear friend the only one who
can shut this mouth is Jesus Christ who
gave this mouth the only one who gave me
this tongue is the one who's going to
take it away no one else so until the
day Jesus calls at the day for this
piece of wreck you are nothing I am
nothing all of us are nothing Jesus I'm
inviting you Clash WAP to come back to
the Lord because let me tell you one
thing all of us we will die one day no
matter what you do how rich you are and
you may conquer the world where is
Augustus Caesar where are the Pharaohs
where are the Assyrian Kings where are
the RO the Macedonian Empire where is
the Roman Empire where is the Persian
and the medis Empire where are they Gone
With the Wind never seen but where is
Christ sitting at the right hand of the
father and still conquering and still
ruling and there are millions of of
people coming to Christ as we speak now
this to me is
power this is what happens when you br
bring uh four different Assyrians from
different backgrounds from different
part of the world together and a good
Holy Bible name sponsor
today
uh I love how you dropped the
goodlooking Bishop from Australia twice
multiple times not twice multiple that's
God's work has to be proven by the way
uh uh Rob do you have that link uh for
uh Bishop Mari uh uh the gsas can you
put that up there promoting the Good
Samaritan a society for anybody that uh
listened to this message and you like to
support Bishop mari's asking you know if
there's any way you want to help this is
one way of doing it you can donate here
on this website yes the Good Samaritan
and Aid Society can I also say one thing
too Pat as my as my friend as my brother
tomorrow is your day isn't it what the
book choose your enemies wisely comes
out tomorrow Amazon Barnes & Noble
you're signing a th000 copies this
Saturday at uh Barnes & no and they can
get those at uh value.com correct you
guys are giving them how's that how's
that going no they have to buy it at
Barnes & Noble and I'll meet them there
but they can order right now Amazon all
over the place that's only for the
people that are in Florida but tomorrow
the book comes but this is coming
oute I'm proud of you
congratulations Pat I'm not going to lie
to you I'm not reading anything I'm
going to listen to you when I drive but
but not at night because you got that
soothing like I'm going to crash but Pat
I'm proud of you God bless you this this
is awesome my man by the way this is so
cool man for us to do this I appreciate
everybody coming out you had the longest
drive it was H you know you were three
exits away some of us were half an exit
away some of us live here but whether
you're a Syrian or not our audience is
not an Assyrian audience
yes so 99% of people that were listening
today matter of fact run a poll Rob can
you run a poll are you a Syrian it's
just simple yes no what's that's the
question what's the oh God go watch I'll
bet
you. I think we have to wait just 30
seconds cuz I just want to know I'm very
curious I actually want to know what
percentage how
about D are screen they're like how do I
how do you what would you if you had to
guess uh Bishop tell I think it's 98 to2
it's probably 99 to1 what do you think
that are listening right now 99 are
going to be non Ser I'm going to say
that there's F it's five 5% did you run
the poll I'll say 5% George where can I
see it Rob do I go I think a lot of the
series that are watching are probably
watching it like their their kids put it
up on a
TV wow 19% no way so that it we're
growing baby and just like that
babylon's back Bon
just like that all it was one podcast it
took one podcast one Bishop one George
and Pat wow 8020 is serious that's
pretty impressive I'm impressed all
right okay well fair enough this is good
we're making progress FKS stand up
mishari thank you so much for coming out
jenko thank you for coming out always a
pleasure thank you this was a blast take
care everybody bye-bye bye- bye bye- bye
wow guess
what